INTERESTING, JUSTIN FAULK IS ON
THEE
LOOSE PUCK AND NOW SENDING IT TD
RYAN O'REILLY ON AS QUICK
AS YOU CAN, UNFORTUNATELY RYAN
UP, TO REFOCUS AFTERORES. I NIG.
[CHEERS]
[APPLAUSE] GOOD POSITION, AND KR
AND ABLE TO KNOCK IT BACK OUT TO
CENTER.
LOOSE AL LEAGUE. SIDE HIS ESCAPS
BLUES SENTIMENT CLEANLY, NICEKY.
NUMBER EIGHT, ERIKSSON-EK.
AND HE FIRES IT WIDE.
ERIKSSON-EK ON THE STEVEN SANTIY
FIVE MINUTES OF THE THOUGHT IF
WE ARE GOING TO GO DOWN WITH IS
GOING TO BE WHAT BLUES..
>> THE WILD DEFENSEMAN HAVE DONE
AN STICK CLEAN
AND I BEL ST. LOUIS IT.
DEFLECTING IT TO THE MINNESOTA
ZONE.
TYING IT UP, TARASENKO
T3 MEETING THE WILD DEFEN SCORE.
AND TARASENKO, THE SECOND GOAL
O
MIKKOLA HAS IT FOR THEDS OF TRA.
>> HERE IS KAPRIZOV, H ANGLE SHY
INTERCEPTED, THE EMPTY NET TALLY
FOR ST. LOUIS SHOULD BLUES